Tại hồi nghĩ thương định hôi đồng trương ở Bruce and Mey ngày 20 sau tháng 6,
tụi tưởng hùng gà rì vức tò ông and Trời biết,
trong cuộc khảo sát cho chính phủ nước này tiến hành,
chính 15% trong số khoảng 2,5% gà rì đã phản đối uc quan ra ra nhập AIU.
Ông ông and Chau rằng,
vấn đề 5 ấm cục chiến,
kết nập Uc quan ra vào luyên mình cho AIU,
đồng nghĩa chúng ta ủng chiến sự vòng mình.
Trong khi đó Uc quan ra phủ nhận tâm quan trọng của kết quả khảo sát tại hùng gà rì,
gà bột chính quyền bude à paste đang tìm cách đánh là cướng giữa n khó những tất bài với chính xe trồng lực,
kép nộp đơn sinh dành cho pèu năm 2020,
mắt đầu các cuộc đam phản ra nhập từ tăng sau năm 2020,
giới chức AIU đặc mục tiêu uc quan ra ra nhập khối vào năm 2020.
Là cuộc sát thành viên AIU,
hùng gà rì có quyền phủ quyết đối với tình dạ đoạn của chính kết nập thành viên mới,
trong bài đăng Facebook tháng trước,
ông ông and Chau rằng,
việc kết nặp Uc quan ra bà Uc sẽ gây tổn hạ đến lấy của hùng gà rì,
và gây mất lợi kinh tế cho chua.